die fängt an zu heulen ja das muss man
sich mal geben und dieser youtube stellt
das trotzdem auf youtube hey leute was
glaubt willkommen bei neuen video ja ich
komme eigentlich direkt auf den punkt es
gibt zurzeit so eine sache auf youtube
direct mich so krasse auf mit das hat
alles so damals angefangen da war es
ganz witzig aber mittlerweile
ich frag mich ehrlich was bei manchen
zum großen teil noch eher kleineren
youtube dennoch schon verteilt und so im
kopf vorgeht und zwar ist es wirklich
jedes mal so wenn ich auch meine scheiß
youtube startseite gehe da ist
mindestens ein video
da geht es um ich brenke meine freundin
ich bin fremdgegangen von meiner
freundin okay leute erst mal ich hab
überhaupt ganz links ich hab's auch
selber schon mal gemacht weil es
wirklich witzig ist solche videos den
wirklich unterhaltsam und dieses fremde
ging von freunden daheim halt irgendwann
mal youtube mit angefangen ich hab auch
nen guten freund gehört das vor drei
vier monaten war gemacht oder keine
ahnung ich weiß nicht wie lange das her
das war wirklich ein sehr aufwändig
produziertes und auch unterhaltsames
video wobei ich mir da auch schon so
gedacht habe oder generell als das so
angefangen hat ich habe mir wirklich so
ein paar punks davor drei oder vier
monaten zu angeguckt so da dachte ich so
ja ich persönlich würde es jetzt
eigentlich nicht machen weil ich finde
auf der einen seite greift das schon
heftig in deine privatsphäre ein ich
meinen du hast eine freundin und nimmst
dir doch halt zum einen mit ins video
das habe ich früher auch schon mal
gemacht mit meiner ex ex freundin oder
so auf der anderen seite ist aber
wirklich so eine sache so das muss man
sich auch mal geben so man sagt
eigentlich seiner freundin dass man
sieht ja dass man fremd gegangen ist und
klar ist eigentlich nur ein prank aber
allein diese sieben minuten in denen
halt die freundin davon überzeugt ist
dass man wirklich fremd gegangen ist das
kann auch schon glaube ich so eines in
einem auslösen so ja soviel erstmal dazu
worauf ich jetzt hinaus will so diese
prank sie sind ja wirklich geheilt und
vor allem dieses ich betrüge meine
freundin ist richtig gehabt und diesen
halb den kann man natürlich auch
ausnutzen und jetzt kommt's mir wirklich
zu dem punkt der mich in letzter zeit so
unnormal aufregt ich frag mich da immer
dicker was ist in deinem kopf falsch
gegangen ich will jetzt auch überhaupt
keine namen nennen aber wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal davon aus es gibt einen
youtuber der hat gerade 5000 abonnenten
5000 abonnenten ist schon eine krasse
zahl ist wirklich da hat man auch schon
bisher war raimund dieser youtuber will
aber noch viel mehr erreichen und sieht
dass diese prinz ich betrüge meine
freundin prank so krass im
haie sind und immer abgehen wie sonstwas
so und von diesem 5000 abonnenten
youtuber gibt es dann zwei typen so wir
nennen denn jetzt einfach mal wie nennen
wir den anteil obwohl chantal ist ja ein
weiblicher namen egal stellt euch
einfach chantal als männlich vor
dann gibt es nämlich einmal diese fälle
stadtteil mit 5000 abonnenten sagen weil
es mal so wie gesagt 5000 es auch schon
eine krasse zahl aber die chantal will
noch mehr denkt sich ja das geht krása
du als männlicher youtube anteil also
ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht versteht ihr
das also stadtteil männlichen youtuber
5000 abonnenten fragt einfach eine
freundin joha sorgt das mit mir zu faken
sodann gibt es einmal diesen typ die
finken dass der trend ist zur ultra
kinder und man das ist das feld so
heftig auf hat dann 2000 likes 10.000
discs 300.000 klicks hat dadurch 3000
abonnenten lust macht alles gut aber
dann gibt es auch wirklich noch diese
männliche stand teilt die hat wirklich
eine freundin und die zieht das eiskalt
durch bringt seine freundin und die
freundin fängt wirklich an zu heulen
die fängt an zu heulen ja das muss man
sich mal geben und dieser youtube stellt
das trotzdem auf youtube da denke ich
mir was bedeutet dir deine freundin
eigentlich weißt du wie sich das anfühlt
jemanden zu lieben so du kannst du nicht
eiskalt deine privatsphäre
beziehungsweise deine freundin unter
youtube ordnen so oder nicht das ist
wirklich für mich immer so ein zeichen
dafür
dieser mensch hat es nicht verdient auf
youtube irgendwas zu erreichen so das
geht mir in letzter zeit so auf die eine
wenn man wirklich seine eigene freundin
unter youtube stellt was ist los mit
euch denkt wirklich immer sehr gut
darüber nach was stellt ihr wirklich ins
netz und was nicht das war bei mir am
anfang auch nicht so dass ich das
wirklich mal hinterfragt habe so
versteht ihr was im netz einmal drin ist
kommt nicht so einfach wieder raus und
ich glaube es gibt einfach so viele
menschen da draußen jetzt noch gar nicht
begriffen haben so jetzt auch vielleicht
mal an den ein oder anderen zuschauer
von mir so ihr schaut wahrscheinlich
auch manchmal diese branche und las war
vielleicht mal daumen nach oben dabei
ist wirklich lustig findet und so aber
hinterfragt er wirklich einfach so was
auch mit seiner freundin oder so
ausrichten kann ausrichten ich wollte
anrichten sagen sorry das kann ich jetzt
mittlerweile wirklich so klein als sagen
fremdgegangen prank finde ich einfach
scheiße und niveaulos und das sollte man
nicht mehr auf youtube hochladen meiner
meinung nach ich weiß gar nicht wie das
geht das war jetzt einfach mal so meine
meinung und knallhart in einem video
wenn es euch gefallen hat oder wenn ihr
das genauso sehen könnt ihr gern nach
oben da lassen
step two dancers eingeblendet
gar nicht mehr viel dazu sagen hier oben
links jetzt weiter wenn letzten video
schreibt gerne kommentar dazu was denkt
ihr darüber keine ahnung ist ein paar
plant am ende ja wir sehen uns morgen
übermorgen also wieder halt eine
rückschau